when I was thinking in primary school
when I went to the shop I always got a
candy bar the Milky Way and then
everyone started calling me Mickey for
some reason and then when I was playing
League or like all the other games I
wanted to be Mickey
but then the name was always taken I
just for the next and I suspected
I started in season one like a end up
he's the one I started playing because
my friends told me to try it out I've
been playing like a lot of different
roles until season 3 when I decided to
play support when I was watching like
tournaments from season 1 and on and I
wanted to try it because it seems really
fun and has do anything I wanted to do
and I just worked out cha Chi next I
wanna try to find something back into
this game but X out is getting shunga
way too low
ties in the pool Mickey X gets that one
we weren't too supportive like they want
me to finish school of course and I
wasn't 18 yet so they wanted to make my
decisions I mean make decisions for me
over time they can I got used to me
being handy computer 24/7 and I guess
they kind of become started coming more
supportive towards it and at the end
when they see how big eSports is they
kind of were okay with it
and now they're supporting
a rustle and support they do change at
best support staff family with that
transfer so there have been changes
playing solo queue from stage it's quite
different
I don't think about the enemy players
that much but for myself it's like a lot
different for me gets on stage I just
like I do a lot of stupid mistakes so
don't think that much not that
aggressive I play really passive if I
don't see any of everyone on the map so
if the criticism is like it makes sense
I can't agree to it and try to like more
work on it if I recognize it recognizing
myself but like some comments pretty
stupid
I just alleys sticking out from flash
after all to attack Nick Nixon to the
tower but the tower goes on to copy so I
still chasing out to make the XS but Q
comes down so let's find a cure we turn
now he's on to copy and I'm Washington
let's flip oh they're pretty wet first
and I actually screamed them when I
tried out for a few teams and then beat
them I was backing them to be like a
bottom team but when I got the offer and
I played with Cobra a lot as we enjoyed
playing with Cobra I just joined then I
saw a lot of potential because they were
like rookies the first flip so and then
I played with all of them like in game
and solo queue and I saw how actually
they are they're all Danish sometimes
pretty annoying when out of a game they
talk about things Ben Danish they don't
understand and just like yeah same guys
in game the talk English it's fine we
understand each other pretty good and
friends all of them it really all really
nice UK motto like yeah it's like a
father figure it can be strict when he
needs to be and he also can have fun
with us like being like a friends
another team fight splice finishing up
this game against h2k 17 kills the six
as flies will go for Zee
on the weak another great game from our
top two team in Europe I think at this
point no one can dispute it and didn't
expect actually to be that successful I
was aiming for like top five at least
yeah when I first played I don't think
it was all because of me I think they
got a lot better and the first place
were like pretty clueless as I could see
from their games but now they just they
know a lot about the game and they teach
me also